first question over here on the fourth
row Steph to your left
Pauline tunas ESPN you guys just had one
of the goodest wins in recent memory
here in the finals yeah nobody's really
celebrating can you just speak to like
the family like connection that you guys
have it was striking to see Bob Myers
and klay Thompson and Steve Kerr feeling
so somber after such a great win can you
speak to that please everybody gets so
wrapped up in know chasing championships
and the greatness that you see on the
floor but life is more important in
terms of caring about an individual and
and what they're going through on a
daily basis and you see I mean the
commitment and and the challenges and
just the what's been thrown at Katie you
know this this whole year really and he
gave us what he had he went out there
and sacrificed his body and you know
turned out so a part of our mentality
and like the experiences the shared
experiences that we have as a team and
what we've all been through that's way
more important than anything that have
is out there you know long-term anything
that happens on the court and I just
feel so bad for him to be honest like
that's nobody should have to go through
something like that especially with this
this stage that we have third row in the
back Steph Jonathan show with dia TV
what did you say to Cady after the
injury and What did he say to you I said
I know it's a kind of an emotional
moment all the way around something told
me just to go back there and I really
don't know what I said or what he says
just
sucks man like I don't really know what
else to say about it so that's it Ramona
in the back
staff Ramona Shelburne ESPN Bob Myers
was in here and he and he said the
people that question whether he wanted
to get back we're wrong Kevin is one of
the most misunderstood people he's a
good teammate and I'm lucky to know him
what do you think Bob means when he says
he's one of the most misunderstood
people when you were on this this level
of greatness and everybody's kind of
poking and pride and trying to you know
narrate your story and tell you who you
are who you should be with decisions you
should make constantly over and over and
over again it's part of you know what
comes with this territory but it's just
when you get to know somebody and see
how genuine they are and how committed
they are just playing a basketball and
having fun and and living life a certain
way you root for those type of guys and
like you said whatever his outward
appearance is or whatever he says to the
media or whatever like then a date of
people that know him know what type of
guy is and you know how special of an
individual he is so all those emotions
come into it when you see him go down
like that where he's giving us
everything he has and it's not even
about you know this serious is about
long-term you know
his mindset and being able to get back
to the player and the person that he's
shown you know consistently over over
the course of his career Chris standing
over here Chris is Yahoo Sports
stuff for you left you touched on it a
little bit but out of all the players
that walk Kevin Durant all the way back
to the locker room you the only one that
was still in the game at that time and
you know within the NBA final stays when
your timeouts are limited and the
seconds are going by you guys got to get
a play up why did you feel it was so
necessary to kind of go at that point
sometimes the spirit tells you what to
do you don't really make decisions you
just act on it so I can't tell you what
went through my head I just felt right
second row on your right Stef match and
I'm in Bury news group are you able to
put into words the challenge of
regrouping after something like that is
it more something that said or is it
just based off instinct I don't know I
mean it's gonna be a rough go in terms
of just trying to recalibrate we've been
up until this points have been about you
know our hope that he could play and I
hope to stay alive in this series and
you know the emotional roller coaster
what tonight was get on this flight
tomorrow go back to the drawing board
when we get home and I think the biggest
thing the biggest advantage is you know
being at Oracle Arena one more time
where our fans can really get behind us
and you know we're going out to will
ourselves you know for another 48
minutes to stay alive and whatever's
going to take from every single guy in
in that juror in our Jersey so I I don't
know really what the what if there's
gonna be a speech in the locker room or
if there's going to need to be worries
at all we understand the moment and I
think we can we can rightly consider how
the second half went tonight left side
over here Steph after Kevin went down
the crowd almost cheered can you maybe
give some of your reaction to that
I've been in the city for I've lived
here really enjoyed the people and their
passion and excitement for not only the
game but just when you coming into it
just and enjoy your life and the nice
people very confused around on that
reaction it's not my experience with you
know people of this city and I commend
obviously Danny Green and Kyle Lowry
especially I think they were the ones
that were kind of signaling to the crowd
like let's let's check ourselves a
little bit understand that this is about
an individual a human being and not oh
shoot he's out he's hurt we won the
championship like that wasn't part of
there in the initial thought and you
hate to see to see that when the guy's
going you know through pain like that so
again that's not my experience with this
city and I just hope that ugliness
doesn't show itself again as we go
forward in the series last week front
right Robert Denmark Steph Valeri Ruby
Nova sport what kind of statement was
made tonight about the character of this
team and also about the mindset going
back to Oakland clay said you're gonna
keep fighting for Kady now I mean we've
made a lot of different statements over
the course of these five years and you
know win or lose I don't feel like we
need to prove anything anymore
it's just about can we get the job done
or not and obvious like I said tonight
was emotional roller coaster from start
to finish and we have another game to
play on Thursday so we'll be ready for
it but there's no more statements need
to be made about who we are as a team in
our heart and our competitiveness and
whatnot we want to win this championship
and we'll give everything we got but I
think we're done with no
proving people wrong or making bold
statements with our play with people
know who we are
Robert Robert LaSalle BSO even though
Kevin was hurt he went to Instagram and
he said dubnation gonna be loud as F for
game 6 I'm hurting deep in my soul right
now I can't lie but seeing my brothers
get this win was like taking a shot of
tequila I got new life LOL hashtag dubs
well how does that make you feel even
though he's hurting that he's still you
know thinking about you guys thinking
about game 6 still being a leader and
trying to let you guys know that even
though you guys feel so bad that he's
gonna be right there with you thinking
it goes back to what bob was saying
about him being misunderstood in terms
of what's important to him playing
basketball is important being a good
human being is important selflessness of
like you say going through a situation
like he's going through right now he has
the initiative to go you know speak to
an entire fan base into no hype less up
as his teammates and his brother so I
expect nothing nothing less or nothing
different in terms of the you know how
he responds to this although he's going
to go through some some some challenges
through this process you know whatever
however long it takes but we're gonna be
there for him for sure
mark last question Steph mark Schwartz
ESPN you know you hear a lot of times
players talk about a guy who goes down
who inspires them it's clear what your
feelings are about this player and this
guy how much can Kevin Durant's spirit
still lift this team in a spot like this
I think just in terms of the opportunity
we have in front of us like you know in
two days you know we'll be suiting up in
front of Oracle Arena and like you said
with the amazing atmosphere and an
opportunity to play for him and to kind
of honor the sacrifice I guess he made
in terms of putting his body on the line
tonight and we're gonna give everything
we got I'd like to say it was guaranteed
a win but who knows how it's going to
end up but we're gonna give everything
we got we're gonna fight we're gonna
compete and I know if we get a chance to
talk to him the next two days that's
what he would expect so I'm excited
about that proposition in terms of what
we have to do on Thursday but the end of
the day is still heartbroken for a guy
that gave everything you have for us
thank you stuff